on passe du père noël aux cadeaux ce
n'est un secret pour personne ils sont
très marquées selon le sexe ou paix et
dînette pour les filles pistolet voiture
pour les garçons faut-il le regretter
dossier signé stéphanie davoigneau
emmanuel maurel manne pour noël océane a
commandé une nouvelle poupée un landau
ce qu'elle préfère c'est jouer au papa
et à la maman avec emma exclusivement
entre copines c'est bizarre pourquoi
c'est bizarre parce qu'il ya ce sage pas
avec les trous que d'habitude ça va
faire mal dans la chambre d'à côté pas
de biberon pas de dînette
le grand frère a commandé pour noël jeux
vidéo et voiture à 10 ans les jouets de
filles c'est la honte
son clip des jeux elle fait pourquoi pas
ce que j'ai fait par exemple
pourquoi ça fait parce qu'ici si je dis
oui après tout l'été lévothyroxine et
pourtant la maternelle canton par
l'atelier cuisine les garçons se
précipitent les jouets siala 10 mai à la
dînette dans la petite cuisine de
frédéric est ce que c'est un jeu de
fille non pas du tout est-ce que
toujours la cuisine quand tu es chez toi
ou à la dig s on va avec des poupées
géantes que zéro sur vingt gardes car
vous comprenez un garçon qui joue à la
poupée
ça fait mauvais genre dans cette
publicité argentine le père de famille
voudrait des jeux un peu plus masculin
pour son fils et pourtant les barbie non
pas l'influent ce qu'on croit sur
l'orientation sexuelle futur les psys
confirme il ne faut pas s'inquiéter si
un garçon joue à la poupée
au contraire il est important de laisser
les enfants jouer avec les jouets qu'il
a envie mais il est aussi important de
lui proposer d'autres jouets pour et
l'âge élargir son champ d'intérêt le
mieux c'est finalement quand les enfants
jouent à plusieurs de sexe différent et
que les jouer comme ça s'échange mais
dans les lettres au père noël la demande
reste très sexuée pour les garçons
numéro un du hit parade cette année les
robots transformables et les circuits
pour les filles les barbies princesse et
le maquillage
même s'il ya parfois des exceptions il
était un masque de zorro avec la cadre
qu est-ce qui malade ne revienne j'adore
d'euros mais c'est un jeu garçons sont
pressés